wanted to ask just obviously about
booker you
you've talked before about him hey take
the first shot available it looked like
he
was dialed into that and more was just
bigger that the first half he had
yeah i mean it it was one of those deals
where
he was feeling it but um
our guys understood that he was feeling
it and so
we we got a number of stops in the first
quarter i mean they only scored 14
points so we were getting out
and running and um we had a conversation
after game two i think or game three it
was game three i think
about their defense is so good
and they shift to the ball so well
you're not gonna
he's not gonna get another look after
the first one presents itself and so
um that was that was the mentality
that we wanted him to have and you know
he just
he's a gifted scorer but it was it was
you know the shot making and and then
the stops
on top of that that you know probably
deflated them a little bit in the first
half but
you know it was an impressive first half
i'm not quite sure how many points he
had in the first
first half maybe 33 or something like
that
but it was a special special night for
him and um
to do that in a close-out game is
is really cool and so i was i was happy
for him happy for our team
and certainly you know happy to be
moving on
all right monty williams after that 113
to 100
win what can you say speaking to the
confidence level of this phoenix team
now
well anytime you have chris paul you're
going to feel confident and listen i
i want to say two things number one
devin booker he took a big step
because now he's like okay i'm an
all-star
now you get a chance to show everybody
right now because there's nothing left
but the good teams
same thing with trey young you had to
you hit the nail on the head earlier
you know because they asked me in
atlanta every week what about trey young
he's not getting credit i said
because he's never made the playoffs but
now he not only has he made the playoffs
he won a series that's when you start
getting credit
so those two guys are good they're
getting these young kids they say
flowers now
but i want to say something about
because you know living in phoenix i'm
beat over the head about deandre ayton
i was so proud of that kid this series
he played
great this entire series you know uh
i'm you know i want to you always want
to see good players break through
and become consistent but man uh
trey devin and deandre ayden i'm not
going to say ayden's on those other two
level yet
but you know they would tell like how's
he gonna do against anthony davis
and obviously anthem davis would you
know but the
game one was to me i told you game one
was the most important game of this
series uh then because
they lost the next two but game one they
set the tone but man i'm happy for my
city
and my dream of my poverty
i'm back to poverty the uh with my
blazers too
well we'll get to that in just a minute
but devin booker had 47 points
in this game and where does that rank in
playoff performances
uh point totals against the lakers in
the postseason sleepy had 51
a.i 48 devin booker third on that list
then you got hondo and zeke
sleep in floyd a good dude from the past
yes indeed sleep
isaiah thomas the great the greatest
little man ever probably